always here in bolivia there are
men of machismo
[Music]
who told us how a woman can
climb the mountain they are doing us
harm
yoani except to my companions I told them
why we can't go to scales more
than men
another critic to this day continues to
criticize us  but we
show them with deeds not with words
[Music]
my name is jimena lidia footprints I dedicate myself
to climbing mountains well our half
foundation that is to say the cholita from La Paz
the cholita we have a hat we have
a blanket what an entrepreneur we always
also wear the earrings that  It
cannot be missing,
we have formed an association
of only single women climbers,
we are currently securitas, more
before we went as
high mountain cooks, but we always had that
desire not to go to the summit and see
how it felt on the flat
in December 2015.
we did not put in the quotas and
now he throws us through the field
we are not going to take off our clothes  Cholita's house
because that's how we want to climb
[Music]
for me it's the most beautiful thing a woman
can feel good friends because they think
I'm a little crazy
because babies and moms the truth is
that she's going to do these things
well well I tell them  to make so much more
understanding of the age
when we go to climb we feel
free from everything
[Music]